ebola in deutschland elektroflugzeug wir
den serie gebaut und der musikgeschmack
änderte sich seit 1960 nur dreimal
das sind drei der fünf themen jetzigen
clixoom topfen ist chemie im trinkwasser
proben wiesen chemikalien im trinkwasser
nach im zuge einer studie der
pennsylvania state university wurden in
trinkwasserproben chemische bestandteile
nachgewiesen dieselben chemikalien
findet man beim fracking beim fracking
wird mit hilfe von wasser und
chemikalien gas und erdöl aus dem
erdreich gedrückt kritiker der fracking
methode äußerten schon häufig bedenken
gegenüber dieser methode ist bestehe die
gefahr dass die chemischen substanzen
ins trinkwasser gelangen könnten
nahe der stelle wo die untersuchten
proben entnommen wurden ist genau ein
solcher fracking standort in betrieb
die bedenken der kritiker scheinen also
bestätigt worden zu sein
die konzentration der chemischen
elemente im wasser ist jedoch so gering
dass die grenzwerte nicht überschritten
worden wären
ebenso sei das trinkwasser aufgrund von
vernachlässigten sicherheitsvorkehrungen
mit den chemikalien in kontakt gekommen
während sie korrekt befolgt wurden
korrekt umgesetzt worden wäre das
wahrscheinlich nicht passiert bohrlöcher
wurden nicht ausreichend verschalt und
lagerbecken wiesen mängel auf
schleudersitz an rakete angebracht 26
die erste private us raumfahrt firma
macht wieder einmal auf sich aufmerksam
diesmal nicht mit einem crash bei der
landung sondern vielmehr bei einer
möglichen rettungsaktion für astronauten
demnächst sollen schleudersitz ähnliche
vorrichtungen an raketen angebracht
werden um die crew im notfall in
sicherheit bringen zu können
diese woche lief der erste 90 sekunden
testversuch dies von spacex entwickelte
thüringen rakete wurde mit einer puppe
bemannt und in richtung himmel
geschossen etwa anderthalb kilometer
über dem boden verließ der bemannte teil
die rakete und machte sich auf den
sicheren sinkflug bereit nach florida
gegen die kapsel mit drei fallschirm zu
wasser in sekunden wird das raumschiff
von der trägerrakete abgetrennt so
könnten astronauten bei komplikationen
die einen weiteren flug zu einem
erheblichen risiko machen würden
gerettet werden bisher war das nicht
möglich die crew des space shuttles
challenger verlor dadurch ihr leben
schon kurz nach dem start im jahr 1986
geplant ist der erstflug mit dem
eingebauten schleudersitz und einer
besatzung allerdings erst 2017 ebola in
deutschland aufregung in bochum 1 in
bochum aufgefundener mann wurde am
sonntagabend von feuerwehrmännern in die
düsseldorfer uniklinik gebracht verdacht
auf ebola rund 10.000 menschen starben
ja bereits an ebola jetzt scheint die
krankheit auch wieder mal nach
deutschland gelangt zu sein die klinik
und die stadt düsseldorf gaben bekannt
dass sich der mann nun in der sonder
isolierstation befindet er würde dort
unter beachtung der höchsten
sicherheitsvorkehrungen behandelt werden
ursprünglich käme der mann aus guinea
ein land das als eines der heftigsten
krisengebiete für ebola gilt zuständige
behörden äußerten sich zu der gefahr die
der mann mit sich bringen könnte es sei
sie sei nicht allzu groß sowohl der
transport des mannes als auch der
aufenthalt in der station stelle keine
bedrohung dar berichten der
weltgesundheitsorganisation who zufolge
aber man bereits die wahrscheinlichkeit
eines übergriffs auf andere länder
dramatisch einnehmen können in afrika
das scheint ja inzwischen alles sich
dramatisch beruhigt zu haben gott sei
dank schon viele elektroautos sind auf
den straßen unterwegs nun soll es auch
elektro flugzeuge geben im april 2014
testete die airbus group ihr erstes
elektroflugzeug derry fan 1.0 schon 2014
stellte er eine enorme entwicklung in
der flugzeugbranche da jetzt ein jahr
später arbeiten die techniker an einem
neuen elektroflugzeug es soll bis zu
zwei personen transportieren können und
eine geschwindigkeit von 160 kilometern
pro stunde erreichen der -fans 80 wiegt
etwa 500 kilogramm ist sieben meter lang
und fliegt etwa knapp eine stunde lang
airbus möchte diese innovation jetzt in
serie produzieren etwa 100 exemplare vom
fenster punkt null sind in auftrag
gegeben worden
kaum ein jahr ist es her dass der fn das
erste mal geflogen ist und schon wird
sich der kopf über den nachfolger des
nachfolgers zerbrochen
der event 4.0 soll bis zu vier personen
transportieren und mit hilfe eines
ladegerätes an bord seine flugdauer in
etwa verdreifachen
es geht also ziemlich schnell voran mit
dem elektro fliegen seit 1960 hat sich
der musikgeschmack erst dreimal
verändert informatiker der university
queen mary in london hatten sich mit den
musikgeschmack und dessen entwicklung
auseinander gesetzt in ihrer arbeit
stießen sie auf ein unerwartetes
resultat der musikgeschmack der menschen
in den usa habe sich nur dreimal
maßgeblich verändert 1964 1982 und 1991
desweiteren stuften sie mit ihrer arbeit
die bedeutung der beatles und der
rolling stones für die musik herab auf
dieses ergebnis sind die experten durch
eine betrachtung der top-100 hits der us
charts gelangte über 17.000 lieder haben
sie genauer unter die lupe genommen
unter die evolutionsforschung lupe der
musik war sie ab 1960 bis 2010 haben sie
sämtliche top 100 hitze hits durch ein
computerprogramm sortieren lassen es gab
kaum größer veränderung ausser in diesen
drei jahren
da konnten außergewöhnlich starke
veränderungen festgestellt werden das
programm machte die informatiker auf
drei jahreszahlen eben aufmerksam
1964 galt beispielsweise schon rock als
sehr beliebt genau da konnten die
forscher erkennen dass die beatles und
die rolling stones eigentlich gar nicht
die rock begeisterung initiiert haben
vielmehr schwammen sie nur mit dem strom
der zeit rock war schon vor ihnen eine
immer beliebter werdende musikrichtung
einen weiteren umschwung in der musik
fanden sie 1983 new wave electro musik
und hard rock begeistert immer mehr
menschen andere musikrichtungen wie
beispielsweise noch 1964 der so beliebte
soul verlor viele anhänger größer als
die letzten beiden veränderung war die
im jahr das hat 91 o pop regierte die
charts folgende künstler wurden damals
richtig populär
zum beispiel busta rhymes snoop dogg und
viele mehr
die letzten ergebnisse ihrer arbeit
notierten die informatiker 2010 sie
fanden ein nahezu erhöhtes spektrum an
musik arten vor
die lieder unterschieden sich kaum
trotz dieser etwas negativen
entwicklungen gehen die forscher davon
aus dass es so nicht weitergehen wird
und auch mich kann die musik wird zu
mehr vielfalt gelangen ist gebe keine
anzeichen dafür dass die entwicklung
weiterhin einen so negativen lauf nimmt
das will ich auch hoffen warum musik
sehr dem geschlechtsverkehr ähnelt haha
und wie man musik in therapien verwenden
kann
das erfahrt ihr in diesem video hier
oben zu rap und zum block kommt ihr hier
täglich news wissenschafts man sagt dass
jeder mensch einen musikgeschmack hat
die anderen eher mögen eher ruhige musik
die anderen eher laut und wilde und so
weiter und so fort wie würdet ihr euren
eigenen musikgeschmack benennen ich will
mal so eine kleine umfrage unter dem
video machen was habt ihr für eine
musikgeschmack schreibt es in die
kommentare